sometimes things just aren't what they
seem and if you're watching this video
you probably should not buy this
MacBook when Apple announced the $1599
MacBook at their event I was super
excited because this is the first time
we have such a low price for this new
14in design which I absolutely love it's
actually one of my favorite Pro Design
designs because not only do we have two
Thunderbolt ports but we also have the
HDMI and a fullsize SD card reader along
with Max safe which is just so nice to
use unfortunately though Apple made a
lot of compromises some which cost them
money to make this machine worse and to
try to get you not to buy it which
unfortunately is exactly what I'm going
to do in this video because it doesn't
make a lot of sense now on the outside
it is great great the keyboard is
fantastic we have the touch ID and the
really nice trackpad and with that the
six speaker system sounds phenomenal
better than most Windows laptops even
fat thick ones now the display also has
120 HZ promotion and 1600 nits xdr which
means it's super bright and beautiful
for watching HDR movies and videos and
it is also great for Content creators
that might be utilizing that display but
it's what's on the inside which starts
to ruin things when Apple showed off the
inside design I immediately noticed the
single fan whereas every other 14in
MacBook has dual fans built in and if
you didn't know it actually costs Apple
more money than to just use the previous
design now yes the previous 13in M2
MacBook Pro also had a single fan but
that machine didn't hit 108° C in simple
testing and the fan didn't run as loud
because the new M3 chip even with its
nice 3 nmet design runs a lot more power
and because of that when we compared it
to the M2 Pro 14 in the single fan was
running super high and Loud compared to
silent on the M2 Pro and the crazy thing
is that M2 Pro machine has gone as low
as
$1600 just like the M3 version but it
has more CPU power and a lot more
Graphics power as well so even though it
uses more wattage and puts out more heat
it doesn't struggle because of its dual
fan design now you might say that you
don't care about a system running hot
and loud but that is only the beginning
of the differences but first I've got to
show you guys the best gift for the
holiday season the ridge wallet it's the
thinnest wallet that holds up to 12
cards plus cash with over 30 durable
colors and styles and RFID blocking with
a lifetime guarantee you can even get
30% off if you buy a matching key case
which holds up to six keys without
jingling so shop the holiday sale at
ridge.com maxtech and get up to 30% off
through December 20th and use my link
for a chance to win a ridge bundle worth
$44,000 thanks Ridge for sponsoring the
channel so if we compare the M3 14in for
1,600 bucks to the previous 14in models
not only do we have that single fan
difference but we also have a difference
in HDMI and display outputs the M2 Pro
can support ak60 4K 120 output so it's
more powerful and with that the M3 model
is limited to just one single display
which was fine with an M1 MacBook Air or
the cheaper machines but on this one
that is just another limitation now with
that it also only comes with 8 GB of RAM
and in the past we've had a lot of Apple
apologist say hey a MacBook Air is not
for pros or even the M2 Pro is not for
pros and that might make sense a little
bit at the lower end but this is a prole
machine and in 2023 pretty much
2024 having 8 gigs just does not make
sense with the first Apple silicon M1
chips it didn't matter that much because
even though they were fast they were not
being limited but with the M2 we started
to get some limitations and now with the
M3 we see significant ones now of course
you can spend $200 more an upgrade to 16
gigs which is exactly what we did and we
made a full comparison and here not only
do you have much lower performance just
running one task with nothing else
opened and that right there proves the
difference with just Ram that we didn't
see in the past but once you open up
some simple web browsing tabs this 8 gig
system starts to slow down whereas the
16 gig doesn't at all and then if you
care about multitasking the 8 gig
version ends up being 2 and 1 half times
slower than with nothing opened where
the 16 gig doesn't change at all and
then looking at the M2 Pro that you can
get discounted that thing is even faster
that is why we should not have 8 gigs in
a system like this and of course if you
upgrade you're at
$1,800 but the problem is Apple doesn't
want you to and to prove that if you
look at their next up configuration for
the M3 it stays with 8 gigs and you just
get one tab of storage which of course
you can always add an external storage
drive to your Mac or you can use cloud
storage but you can never upgrade your
RAM and the sad thing is people that
need a machine quickly either online or
going in into a store cannot get 16 gigs
they're going to buy 8 gig versions that
are limited now of course some people
will say well not everybody that's
buying this $1600 machine is a pro they
don't care about performance but I would
say you can say that for one of the
MacBook airs but if you're buying this
machine you should care and honestly I
think that if somebody is looking at
this machine the only people that should
buy it are those that want this newer
design with the extra ports but are
mainly doing email and watching videos
and listening to music on the nice
screen and speakers and the reason why I
said that if you're watching this video
you should not buy this machine that's
because you obviously care about getting
a good value so for $200 more you can
get an M3 Pro that is significantly
faster it's faster in CPU performance it
is much faster in graphics performance
especially if you can use the rate
tracing cores and in over overall
performance it could be more than twice
as fast for an extra 400 bucks or just
200 if you are going to be upgrading
your RAM which realistically you should
with the M3 chip and the thing you
really have to think about is that most
people that buy a Macbook they keep
their machine for 5 to 6 years or if
you're into heavy productivity that
averages 2 to 3 years so that difference
in price of about 200 bucks really is
nothing in the grand scheme of things
and the value that you end up getting
and if you really can't spend more than
$1,600 you can get an M2 Pro that is
pretty much better in almost every way
or if you don't care about performance
you might as well get a 15in MacBook Air
which not only is thinner it is lighter
you have a larger display and the
performance of the M2 with 8 gigs is
barely slower than the M3 version and it
still has that same liation with One
external display I would prefer this
machine as long as you don't need the
absolute best speakers in a small size
they are not as good but they are still
better than most Windows laptops so even
though Apple gave us this M3 machine for
1,600 bucks with the new design that
does not mean that it's a great value it
is literally set up as a stepping stone
to upgrade the price to 1,600 from the
previous 1300 for the 13-in MacBook Pro
while at the same time giving smart
consumers the push to end up spending
more money on the M3 Pro or the M32 Pro
machine which it does suck to tell you
guys to spend more money but me being a
responsible reviewer that is what I have
to tell you guys to do it is a much much
smarter purchase in pretty much every
single way so we finally have an M3
machine that comes in at a lower price
but even if it seems like it's a better
value it is not you guys let me know
your thoughts down in the comment
section below check out the ridge wallet
as well click that Circle above to
subscribe and check out one of those
great videos right over there this has
been Max and I'll see you in the next
[Music]
one